Je n'ai pas d'informations spécifiques sur un crime récent ou historique connu
sous le nom de « crime de maracons » en Suisse.
Il est possible que vous fassiez référence à un événement moins médiatisé ou local
qui n'a pas été largement rapporté dans les sources internationales ou principales.
Si vous avez des détails supplémentaires ou si cet événement s'est produit
après ma dernière mise à jour en septembre 2021,
je pourrais ne pas avoir l'information.
Pour obtenir l'information la plus récente ou détaillée,
je recommanderais de consulter les actualités locales
ou les archives de la police de la région concernée.